we haven't done this for a while some
race my case oh let's do it
so in this one a a mother was walking
with her ten month old baby in a mall to
meet her husband and son in arcade and a
woman ran up from behind and punched her
10 month old baby for no reason
she took off there was swelling bruising
around the eye and after posting the
security footage on social media they
apprehended the suspect that's a crazy
white girl prayin F yeah it sounds like
a schizo Freni a thing so I'm gonna take
it out of a I don't see a lot of Asians
get to phrenic so I'm gonna take it out
of the Asian realm I'm gonna I'm kind of
in black or white what are the races are
there no excellent could be angry what
if the baby was of a different she
cheated and the baby was with a
different man and he punched the baby
like a novela [ __ ] baby dog you don't
say like ten years ago
yeah I agree I'll say that dude you know
who I represent today Houston but we do
what everyone takes to put some wins
baby had to take those medals from you
we had to take those to do that baby
could be stealing signals they don't
make me scoop some [ __ ] yams into
your [ __ ] coffee I'm going white I'm
going white girl on drugs thought the
baby was the demon punch in the face
same white I'm awaiting I imagine Asian
for somebody's good agent people they do
hit young people yep
that's um yep good for them a is that
true though Asian parents will hit their
kids I'm sure I've been here I used to
get my ass BIA yeah wow really yeah I
think all ethnicities hit their kids
with hitting other kids is the question
other people's kids huh I'll spank your
other kids like 15 years ago it got
really weird like spank your kid when
Adrian Peterson spanked his kid and
everybody got mad well used a switch
yeah I used to beat the [ __ ] out rather
that he hit me with a switch then he hit
me with Adrian Peterson's hand
it's not him lining his son up and his
son has to try to tackle is a small
piece of a tree dude young that would do
that [ __ ] chant remember that's why
you had to leave Minnesota yeah locked
him [ __ ] that kid up though he didn't
[ __ ] that kid up dude that kid had a
couple of licks on his legs I'm not
saying that I feel like you're anti kid
today which is kind of weird but it's
also it's the rose the gloves the lunch
lady gloves I don't know what it is dude
maybe you're right man maybe it's 90-day
fiance just ruining my hope and
relationships that should give you hope
dude if those scumbags can figure out
what about the dad from Tennessee that's
always acting like he's a mine I feel
like I feel like he always is like
making things with his eyes like he's
stuck in a box but isn't real telling
you buddy all right what are we talking
about
I thought Adrian Peterson dude I say why
the woman who punched the baby was Asian
oh yes Asian anyone I did man do we
watch it yes victim was 10 month old
Alexia
s-sir although Alexia was all smiles
today remnants of yes baby
for no reason I've never seen a woman
before we hadn't talked to anyone we
have no idea why she would hit our
daughter was she in the girl or the the
daughter
look she swung for the mom yeah now did
she think the little girl was a bat
what's going on here looks like Boris
Johnson from the England I think you
failed to go over anything because you
[ __ ] some issue us for sure Tom a
chronic Haim at the time he canceled on
Brad to hit a sore foot
well that bro there when you have
sold-out shows and three days before
because you had a runny nose you
canceled on Brea I was having an
exorcism you I want to take my own life
what's next you can punch a baby that
maybe looks just like a young boy or or
or the lady from thousand-pound sisters
yes she's the last pound the last pound
okay number two
so Chin's in the lead bullsh in cheating
using his own race
that's insider trading that's used to
know yeah you get to wear the jersey now
a woman was found guilty after of firing
into a McDonald's restaurant at 28th
Street and Madison in February because
she was upset that the restaurant
apparently left the bacon off her
cheeseburger for the second time that is
frustrating but where does she have that
peace from no I don't feel like you see
a lot of black women with guns you know
I feel like you see a lot of black men
with guns and you see a lot of black
women with gun really
and it was a woman it said net yeah guns
like women hmm black okay stick in the
black
I'll go black man I mean I definitely
convinced you huh 28 in Madison it
sounds like an area where there might be
some black people wow my mission I wrote
the game as a layup yeah oh yeah she's
got a gun
okay hold on it was black home with
extremely short hair
if you descend extremely short hair or
black one with semi fade I would have
been like yeah possible pistol the amber
rose right though upset that's a bummer
alright last one I can imagine it gets
heated at some of those joints yeah I
mean sometimes my post may throw our
sushi I forget my eel sauce well that
sucks when they forget something if you
make baked eel sauce it makes the meal
yeah you [ __ ] me used to make fake eel
sauce at home it's gonna find the meal
yeah you gotta get a goldfish out of the
tank and convince that bastard to give
up his sauce you gotta hold a small
plastic gun to his head pissing his cub
boy 35 year old man faces multiple
charges he blamed on head-on driving
while having intercourse the arrest
stemmed from an off-duty deputy
witnessing a four-runner
fish tailing all over the road and
tearing up a county highway the deputy
could smell a strong odor of alcoholic
beverage and once they stopped the man
he said he was having sex with his
girlfriend yeah okay
also just pull over though you know he's
like yeah for runner-runner fishtailing
listen to that kind of music
white drunk yeah highway I can see the
girl that was up to have sex in the
4runner yeah I'm a high-end he looks
like Boris Johnson a little bit I think
this is the first day we kind of got all
them rights of that first one
yeah it was better than most
[Music]